[Applause]
all of the systems beliefs emotions and
experiences that we call life are taking
place on a tiny rock floating through
space during our time here we've
discovered that our rock is one of the
only ones that has all the conditions
necessary for sustaining life what we
can't figure out for sure is what spark
brought together all these conditions
that led us into existence what clues
have we found so far and why does it
seem like life on earth came from
something extraterrestrial this is what
if and here's what would happen if life
didn't originate on earth the earliest
signs of life on Earth are molecules
that are so complex that some scientists
say it's unlikely they just popped up
here so what if they formed somewhere
else in space first and then travel to
our planet how would they get here no
one knows for sure how or where life on
Earth started but there are plenty of
conflicting scientific theories out
there to better understand them let's
start with something we can all agree on
earth is about four and a half billion
years old and some of the earliest
fossils we found are about 3.7 billion
years old so we know that life started
at some point in between and that's
where things start to get complicated
some of the earliest evidence for life
on Earth contains a complex molecule
called ribonucleic acid or RNA RNA is
made up of thousands of smaller
molecules that are connected in a
particular pattern and it was one of the
driving forces behind life on Earth but
the big question that divides the
scientific community is where did RNA
come from well one option is that it
came from outer space and no we don't
mean by way of advanced aliens planting
their seeds although that would make for
an interesting video anyways what we're
talking about is called panspermia the
idea that living organisms or genetic
materials could have been transported to
earth through some sort of natural
phenomenon like a
asteroid it might sound crazy but it's
actually plausible in 2012 Danish
scientists found the building blocks of
RNA in a star system 400 light-years
away proving that the compounds
necessary to forge life on earth could
be created in space
but then how did they end up on earth
well there are two main theories and
both involve asteroids number one an
asteroid could have brought these
genetic materials to earth by crashing
into its surface or number two an
asteroid could have crashed into Mars
hit a spot that contained microorganisms
and sent the debris into space which
eventually found its way to earth both
of these instances have happened before
and research shows that some life-forms
like bacteria and fungus could
definitely survive the trip to our
planet but some scientists remain
skeptical choosing to believe that life
on Earth was sparked by natural
phenomena like lightning or good
old-fashioned chemical reactions so even
if panspermia doesn't turn out to be our
true origin story it doesn't mean that
asteroids aren't spreading life to any
of the other billions of planets out
there right now laying the groundwork
for future civilizations like ours but
that's a topic for another what-if
[Music]